what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
man did you guys really think I was
gonna make you guys wait a week did you
really think I was gonna make you wait a
week for the end of secret Empire no not
at all we're doing this injustice style
hopefully you guys are excited anyway
so this is the conclusion this is the
end of secret Empire now the cool thing
about this is that secret Empire at
least in my opinion is one of the
coolest stories about Captain America I
mean I get that there are some people
out there who are just like no my
opinion is an absolute I don't like it
no one should like it because I don't
like it that's fun I mean I think it's a
really cool story but the idea here is
that with with you know the the Hydra
Captain America with secret Empire it's
not suddenly an all-new all-different
marvel thing it is to a degree but it's
actually been one cohesive story that's
been going all the way back to castaway
in dimension Z and that's why I like it
is because it's just one great big huge
tale of Steve Rogers as a character
which is why I say it's so cool is
because we've we've read a million
stories where Captain America has led
the Avengers into you know into a
conflict against a million enemies we've
seen that a million times before
throwing his shield fighting the bad
guys if they become rinse and repeat
stories and so the idea was secret
Empire was to switch all that up to stop
doing the same rinse repeat stories all
the time to give us like a darker
character what would happen if Captain
America Steve Rogers became a bad guy
and so what this does at least you know
with the whole iron male cast away in
dimension Z that all went all the way
back to the whole idea of C Rogers
losing a Super Soldier Serum that's
really all it was when he lost his Super
Soldier Serum he was basically aged up
he began to age extremely fast and so
what ended up happening is he basically
handed his mantle over to Sam Wilson now
of course Sam Wilson have been the
sidekick for quite some time and so it
made sense that if anybody was going to
be the next version of Captain America
it would be Sam Wilson because he's
fought alongside him so much longer
because of this when all-new
all-different marvel started with Steve
Rogers still being an older guy what
ended up happening is there was an event
that was written called Avengers
standoff and what Avengers standoff dead
is it basically brought in the idea that
shield had basically recreated a
reconstructed a Cosmic Cube using
various charge that it existed all
throughout its history and so on and so
forth and then when they reconstructed
this Cosmic Cube they basically created
a sort of fake paradise they are more or
less warped reality to essentially take
over the lives of villains we're just to
say blind them from what was really
going on it was a very
matrix esque kind of situation the
result here was that when the Avengers
learned about what was going on it was
considered a violation of human rights
and so as you would expect the Avengers
responded the Avengers basically took
down the entirety of Pleasant Hill you
know the whole assault on Pleasant Hill
storyline so on and so forth but in the
midst of all this the Red Skull had
become aware of the fact that the Cosmic
Cube had become sentient but the idea
here is that with shield being brought
down with Red Skull learning that the
Cosmic Cube was sentient Red Skull in
turn used the Cosmic Cube to simply sit
down and say okay fine if I've never
been able to beat Steve Rogers fighting
him hand-to-hand then I'll just alter
his past and I'll just make him a Hydra
agent using the Cosmic Cube and that's
exactly what happened now this
eventually led to a rift between Steve
Rogers as a Hydra agent and Red Skull
because you know Steve Rogers said Red
Skull is not really Hydra he's just
pretending to be Hydra ultimately
killing the Red Skull taking over Hydra
himself and then launching this campaign
to take over the entirety of North
America with his sights set on the world
now the other half of this is we picked
up with something called the vanishing
point and we didn't really know what the
vanishing point was all we knew is that
the classic Steve Rogers which is to say
the version that existed before secret
empire which is running around this
vanishing point now eventually we
learned the vanishing point was just the
mind of cause of copic the Cosmic Cube
it was basically this classic Steve
Rogers being a memory of who he used to
be and so again it essentially kept the
concept of him alive even if he wasn't
alive in the traditional sense now what
this does is with that kind of catching
us up to a degree again you know you can
go check out the most recent video to
fully understand what's going on with
this basically boiling down to the
entirety of the earth superheroes taking
on the Hydra Captain America they all do
the best they can but keep in mind the
he's captured all but one shard of the
Cosmic Cube so even if he doesn't
necessarily have the power to warp all
things in existence he's got more than
enough power to take on the various
superheroes and that's exactly what he
does he basically shows up and begins
taking them all down now of course this
coincides with Sam Wilson handing over
his shard of the Cosmic Cube basically
giving up basically saying hey look you
know here here's your shard do whatever
it is that you want to do now in this
moment this is where all the superheroes
lose suddenly Captain America uses the
Cosmic Cube and whisks them all away and
that's par for the course when it comes
to all these
Kosmic stories whether it's the original
secret wars secret Wars - and the
Beyonder came to earth when it comes to
the Infinity Gauntlet infinity war
infinity crusade infinity abyss when it
comes to all those stories it's always
just some being with godlike power wipes
everybody from existence so it's not new
that's routine that always happens is
one of the big complaints that people
have when it comes to those characters
when it comes to those massive story
arcs what do you do when you're facing a
foe who's virtually indestructible now
of course this basically leads to this
sort of re-creation of earth as Hydra
Captain America wants it to be in this
instance Doctor Doom leads the Fantastic
Four
instead of Reed Richards Professor
Xavier and Magneto are considered mutant
revolutionaries and they're executed by
Hydra but suddenly all these issues that
that that Hydra Captain America sees
begin to get whisked away they begin to
go away they begin to vanish and so with
this virtual you know godlike power
that's possessed by Hydra Captain
America with Sam Wilson again popping up
on the scene saying hey look here's my
final shard all these things taking
place what we end up finding out is that
this was all basically a ruse by the
superhero community that they realized
that it'd be almost impossible for them
to directly stop Hydra Captain America
what they needed was someone who would
basically be able to offer them a
counterpoint but what we end up finding
out here is that with Bucky Barnes
having previously been inside the
vanishing point you know with him
knowing that the memory quote-unquote of
the classic Steve Rogers is there what
he basically does is initiate this sort
of rescue mission where he literally
shows up inside of the vanishing point
and then just tries to grab Steve Rogers
classic Steve Rogers and bring him back
now the other half of this is the
character of copic herself the cool
thing about copic as a character is that
again with a cosmic cube that she comes
from having been so newly created the
fact that she's a little girl is
designed to mimic her stage that is to
say how old she is as far as the cosmic
cuba's meaning the Cosmic Cube is like
in its adolescence so to speak but with
the whole character of copic she's
terrified of everything that's going on
because remember she does not see
herself as this all-powerful godly
entity she sees herself as a kid who
could just do some pretty crazy things
and so at the end of the day she doesn't
have the full wherewithal of her powers
more so than that because she sees the
world as
someone who's just basically scared of
what's going on not fully understanding
or regretting her decisions she in turn
tries to run away now this is why
classic Captain America is so important
and this is why people love to classic
Captain American will get a little more
into this you know classic versus Hydra
you know Steve Rogers I hear in a minute
but with classic Steve Rogers he was a
rallying point he was a point by which
despite the fact that you could shoot
him with a gun because that's how he
died despite the fact that you could
knock him out he was a guy that
everybody implicitly trusted he was
first in last out always the guy to be
there to make sure that things ran like
they were supposed to the result was
that people would just follow him no
matter where it was that he would go or
what it was that he wanted to do and
this was basically the scheme that was
pulled with this cosmic hue more or less
being reinstated
it's basically Hydra Captain America
using the power of Copic because she was
too afraid to use it on her own
when is up happening is that with Bucky
Barnes going into the vanishing point
basically into the mind of comic
retrieving her alongside classic Steve
Rogers she basically takes her power
back and everything starts to return the
normal and that's when we get into this
battle of classic Captain America versus
Hydra Captain America and that's the
cool thing here these characters are
able to exist simultaneously because
once a memory and one is not if we had
to sit down and we had to say okay if
we're basing this you know on like the
physical form right like the physical
body which one's the real Captain
America that is Hydra cat this is the
same Captain America we've been seen for
years and years and years just with its
own witness history alter the classic
Captain America that you're seeing right
now with the blue outfit and the a on
his hand all that kind of stuff he's
basically a memory given physical form
and so it's essentially a resurrection
of sorts now of course with this fight
between the two of them it is the
quintessential battle of like freedom
versus security that's really what this
is designed to represent because the
whole story was basically predicated on
that it was the story that created this
kind of argument that really hailed to
that that phrase that's overused you
know those who had sacrificed freedom
for security bottle block you know it's
that whole argument come to bear in this
story because the nature of this is that
these guys both represent two separate
sides both of which are valid if you
guys are familiar myself for nautical
candy and a college story and run a
channel called elder
monster when we talk about games and do
all kinds of cool stuff one of the
discussions that we had recently was we
ran over who was right and injustice was
it was it Superman was it Batman
you know Superman basically wanted to
rule the world through control but he
basically became a dictator
Batman was the guy who was fighting
against him as the rebel in this story
it's much the same way Hydra Steve
Rogers wants to rule the world with
absolute control classic Steve Rogers
says no people need to choose but notice
this both sides are legitimate say for
example that they're you're walking down
an alley and there's a little girl you
know and her parents have just been
killed by a mugger you don't catch the
mugger the mugger runs off the little
girls crying are you really gonna walk
up to her and say look I know we
probably could have prevented this from
happening but you losing your parents is
the price you pay for freedom because
the alternative is that we try to stop
climate everywhere and we restrict
people's rights and things like that are
you gonna be the one to tell that little
girl that well of course not but at the
same time freedom is a necessity and
that's why both these things are so
important is because there's a balancing
act you can't have one in the extreme
you can't have extreme freedom you can't
have you can't have a society where it's
just hey do whatever you want to do
whatever happens happens but you also
can't have a society where you say
nobody can do anything without my
permission first
because at that point things go
absolutely a rot you have to have this
middle ground people can do things but
there have to be consequences for law
and order has to exist checks and
balances have to exist people could
commit crimes but there has to be
punishment for those crimes
you know there's imperfections all
throughout the system as it exists but
you try to make it work as best you can
and ultimately that's the argument
classic Captain America has and that's
why people love him so much is because
at the end of the day he says look
things are screwed up things aren't
necessarily right but in the end the
freedom that we enjoy gives us the
freedom to choose it gives us the
freedom to say what if we don't like the
direction that things are going in what
if we don't like where we are right now
then let's change it because if you walk
up to a person and you say change your
life and you put a gun in their face
don't change their life until that gun
goes away and then once the guns gone
they'll go right back to where they were
before true change has to happen
organically people have to change
because it's fear of where they used to
be versus where they could be that
drives them to keep doing better and
that's the goal of classic Captain
America is look we've made all kinds of
thanks war disease famine we've done all
kinds of terrible things but we can
learn from them we can look at where we
used to be and say why would we want to
go back to that let's go to this let's
look to the brighter future and let's do
that instead Hydra Captain America had a
similar view his idea was to do it at
the barrel of a gun now at the end of
the day it also raises the question if
the ultimate goal is achieved enough
what difference is there and if these
people cared about their freedom so much
then why weren't they fighting for it
and so that really brings out that whole
thing into play raise that whole
question and well you know you can't
stick your head in the sand hoping
things will get better and then complain
when they don't doing things changes
things doing nothing keeps things
exactly as they are and so because of
that in this moment when we basically
have this question of who's the correct
person here Hydra Captain America does
the only thing that he can do grabs the
hammer of Thor in an attempt to lift it
up and prove his worth only to find out
that he can't that he's not worthy
because he no longer believes he is he's
no longer righteous he's no longer the
right guy here now of course this leads
to classic Captain America picking up
the hammer of Thor now this is not the
first time we've seen this but it's
always one of those cool things and
that's why people say well the fact that
he's picked it up so off is the fact of
so many people have lives the hammer a
fork it doesn't really even matter
anymore
that's nonsense that's that's absolute
that's absolutely tomfoolery it is the
context of when the Hammers picked up
that makes it matter in 50 years we can
have stories where a thousand people
lifted the hammer of Thor but the
context in which the Hammers picked up
is what makes it important because this
provides a kind of finality it provides
an answer to that question no classic
Captain America's right
no Hydra Captain America is wrong that's
the end of that there's no discussion
there's no debate
none of that stuff this is how it is and
that's what makes us so cool is because
it's almost like this this sort of you
know mic drop right there's like boom I
hit you with a hammer of Thor might drop
like it's one of those really really
cool mullets it's one of those cool
things but what is it happening here as
things wrap up relatively fast I mean it
basically turns into a rebuilding phase
but one thing to keep in mind is that
despite the fact that things have
changed one thing that that classic
Captain America did not have copic do is
wipe the minds of the whole of humanity
it's important that the whole of
humanity remember though look at
superheroes with a skewed perspective
they look at superheroes and they won't
necessarily trust them again but
at the end of the day they will know
that the superheroes did right by and
the superheroes didn't change anything
trying to make things better again but
again this goes into like the old mega
issue right like it goes into the holo
mega thing it goes into the aftermath
because there is follow-up for all these
various characters and all these things
that have happened but the end of the
day again you know the DNA was kind of
like but the story itself I thought was
pretty stellar I thought it was pretty
solid right it was one of my more
enjoyable experiences with Captain
America but with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you want new hereto
comments explain and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core the guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you